how do we see this in society we have
happy wife happy life it's cheaper to
keep or even the idea of a man cave or
the woman has the whole house and the
man has his little cave in the base and
even just the reputation of Merit you
know we have phrases like women you
can't live with them you can't live
without right indicating that maybe
we're not the easiest to deal with so
basically what happens in the workforce
and in any industry that women go into
is the men will be working they'll be
doing their thing in either the gym the
workplace or whatever they'll have all
these male spaces it used to be bars
gyms and the women will want the
attention from the men they'll think huh
I need that attention from those men so
they got to figure out a way in and once
the women get into the space then they
go in and say it's how you say it I
don't like your tone then they establish
H dreaded HR because think about it guys
are are men really gonna are they gonna
develop HR are the men really suing
people like that oh HR I forgot in
lawsuits he